السعادة هي شيء
ربما
كنت تبحث عنه كثير من الناس لأنهم
تعاملوا مع العزلة
والتباعد الاجتماعي وصحتهم العقلية
أثناء الوباء ، ما بدأ
كصف دراسي شهير في جامعة ييل في 2018
أصبح الآن دورة تدريبية عبر الإنترنت ناجحة للغاية.
للجمهور
بعنوان علم الرفاه ، التحق أكثر من 3.3
مليون شخص بالفعل
في الندوة التي قدمتها المنصة الإلكترونية
كورسيرا ،
قالت الأستاذة المعارة لوري سانتوس
إنها أطاحت بعدد الأشخاص الذين
أخذوا الفصل
أثناء الوباء وانضم إلي الأستاذ سانتوس
الآن
من الرائع أن تكون لديك ، لا يمكنني الانتظار
لأتحدث إليكم حول هذا ، فلنبدأ أولاً
بوصف الدورة الذي يقرأه
في هذه الدورة ، وسوف تشارك في
سلسلة من التحديات المصممة
لزيادة سعادتك
وبناء عادات أكثر إنتاجية مثل
التحضير لهذه المهام
يكشف الاستاذ عن
مفاهيم خاطئة عن السعادة
وملامح مزعجة للعقل تقودنا الى
طريقة التفكير.  هل
والأبحاث التي يمكن أن تساعدنا في التغيير
أخبرنا أكثر
إذا كنت ترغب في هذه الدورة التدريبية وما
يمكن للمشاركين أن يأخذوه منها ،
نعم أعتقد أن أول شيء تتعلمه
هو أن العديد من الأشياء التي نعتقد
أنها ستجعلنا سعداء.  لا
تعمل حقًا بالطريقة التي نفكر
بها وهذا أحد الأسباب التي تجعلني أعتقد
أن الدورة مهمة للغاية ، فنحن بحاجة إلى
تجاوز مفاهيمنا الخاطئة حول
أنواع الأشياء التي نحتاج إلى القيام بها لنكون سعداء إذا
عرفنا الأشياء الصحيحة التي يجب القيام بها
يمكننا أن نقضي وقتنا بالطرق
الصحيحة في الأشياء الصحيحة التي
ستعمل حقًا على تحسين
رفاهيتنا بسرعة كبيرة حقًا للعودة إلى المنزل حول
ما هي الأشياء الصحيحة التي يجب القيام بها مقابل
المفاهيم الخاطئة بسرعة كبيرة ،
نعم المفاهيم الخاطئة تتعلق بالمال
وتغيير  لكن
البحث يُظهر أن ما ينجح حقًا هو
تغيير طريقة تفكيرنا
لتصبح أكثر حضوراً وأكثر امتناناً
وتغيير سلوكياتنا لتصبح أكثر
ارتباطًا اجتماعيًا
وتستغرق وقتًا للقيام بأشياء لطيفة
للآخرين وحتى صحية.  القليل من النوم
وممارسة الرياضة
المرتبطة اجتماعيًا ، وهو
أمر كان صعبًا كما تعلمون جيدًا
خلال هذا الوباء ،
فقد ارتفع التسجيل في الواقع
خلال الوباء ، ما الذي تعتقد
أنه حول الأشخاص المعزولين
الذي دفعهم إلى البحث عن هذا بهذه
الأعداد الضخمة
نعم  نحن نعلم أن قسم الاتصال الاجتماعي
هو ميزة ضرورية للسعادة العالية ،
لذا
فأنت تعلم أن إغلاق العزلة الاجتماعية
كان بالضبط نوع الشيء الذي كان
سيحدث ضررًا كبيرًا على صحتنا
العقلية ولذا أعتقد أن الناس قد توافدوا على
الدورة لمحاولة  احصل على بعض الاستراتيجيات
لكيفية تحسين الأشياء التي يعرفها الناس كيفية
إصلاح
صحتهم الجسدية بشكل صحيح تحتاج إلى
ارتداء قناع والمسافة الاجتماعية ،
لكني أعتقد أن الناس يكافحون حقًا مع
أشياء بسيطة يمكنهم القيام بها لحماية
صحتهم العقلية خلال وقت عصيب
وأنت أيضًا  تعرف على الأشخاص الذين لم تكن
لديهم مصادر التشتيت التي قد تكون لديهم من
قبل ، ثم يُجبرون على الجلوس
في
المنزل ونوعًا من  احسب نفسك
وثانيًا أعتقد أن
هذا كان تحديًا للناس ،
وأعتقد مرة أخرى أن ما أظهره البحث حقًا
هو أن السعادة تتعلق
بسلوكياتنا إذا اخترنا السلوكيات الصحيحة ،
فاستغرق
فترات راحة لتعزيز الثراء الزمني ، واستغرق
وقتًا للامتنان
يمكننا حقًا تحسينه
رفاهيتنا وعليك أن تضع حدودًا وهذا هو الحد
الأدنى وهو ما فعلته
بهذا الرد التلقائي ، كيف تقيس
السعادة كيف تعرف
ما إذا كنت سعيدًا ، نعم نقوم بذلك من
خلال تقرير ذاتي بسيط ، هؤلاء هم
استطلاعات الرأي التي تم التحقق من صحتها جيدًا والتي
يمكننا استخدامها
لتقييم شعور الناس
وما نجده في فصل كورسيرا
هو أنه من قبل إلى ما بعد ،
يرتقي الأشخاص حول نقطة كاملة على مقياس السعادة المكون من 10 نقاط ،
لذا فإن
هذه الممارسات تعمل حقًا
احصائيا